Jen can you give us an example of this
core wound and how it might translate
into maybe a current show that's of
course actually I just watch actually
two series that I love the night manager
and Happy Valley but I'll go into the
night manager in and what was
interesting about both shows is the
wound that happens in episode one that
clearly triggered an old wound is is
something that's revisited in the finale
so we see the powerful wound in the
opening show of both series and then in
the finale we see the character have an
opportunity because the same wound could
happen all over again
and and seeing the reaction is really
what adds depth to the character so in
the night manager we get a sense that
there's a wound that they don't explore
in detail the past wound and that has to
do with when he was in the military and
then the present wound and I'm I don't
want to give away anything that happens
in the pilot because it's so powerful
but the there's a very powerful wound
that happens due to a choice that he
makes and and that wound
you know creates a narrative that has to
do with the idea of love versus the
mission and really understanding the
choices that are made and how they
affect an outcome and and he is
definitely led by love and that can the
flaw is that could get in the way with
what he needs to do professionally and
that again like links back to the idea
of the wound in and I call the other
things as
like a lot of people say people don't
get the wound and I say okay well
another way to think about it is the
series trigger happens to the central
character pushing them into a powerful
dilemma that leaves a void and how does
the pursuit fill the void interesting I
know you've said that in order to be a
strong storyteller you have to be living
and present in your own story and I
think most people would say if they
write something that oh yes that that's
this is it it's right here but when
you've gone back and read something and
given someone notes have you seen you
know what I don't know if they really
are present oh definitely I I think that
you know Mike my feeling is the best way
to tell a strong story is to be present
when your own is happening and I think
that so many of us when our all's lost
moments happen distract ourselves with
work with working out with partying with
anything that will take away the pain
and and I think a large part of the
emotional work that I do with writers is
really helping them be present during
their pain because I often find that
when someone is raw in the middle of the
all's lost moment like they just lost
their mom or dad or their sibling you
know committed suicide I've had clients
that have had to deal with that and
there's a really raw emotional response
to it and and what understandably so and
in what I say is you have to understand
yourself because very often you have to
do the work to heal the wound before
you're ready to explore it in your
writing or many writers are immediately
ready
and therapeutically need to go to the
page to make sense of it so I always
think that when our darkest moments
happen that it is the greatest time to
express ourselves
you